so here we are celebrating your first
album which is shake your moneymaker and
you've decided to do two brothers are
back together which is great as a fan
I'm thrilled for you guys and I'm happy
for you personally you know and let's do
another song from the album if you guys
are up for it let's do it let's do she
talks to angels do you remember
recording this song that you're gonna do
yeah you know you remember actually
being in the studio putting it together
was it particularly difficult for you to
put this so everything was difficult on
your first album because why you've
never worked in a studio before on this
song did you bring to crisp the intro
again is that how it always works I had
I had the song the intro came later on
this one I see but I remember writing it
on and this weird electric guitar and
then I kind of honed it on an acoustic
and then the opposite of what I know
which was playing open tunings which was
kind of you know where the strings are
tuned to a chord instead of a standard
tuning which comes from folk tradition
and a lot of luck for him Nick Drake and
then getting into Keith Richards and
stuff who was famously using those kind
of what are using to open E open E
alright so here it is in open E are we
still doing in an open E yes yes we are
yeah I don't want any nonsense now this
is she talks to angels this is from of
course the great album shake your
moneymaker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she never mentions the word addiction in
certain company
yes she tell you she's an off arm
after you meet her family
[Music]
[Applause]
she paints her I just black is that now
she pulls up shades down tight
[Applause]
sit back
[Music]
painting the only thing to make it
yes that's right
[Music]
and they come
[Music]
the vicar
[Music]
she keeps a lock of hair in her pocket
she wears a cross around her neck
[Music]
and across from someone sick
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Genovese everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well she hates her ass of blackheads a
day
the cheaper the back down tight said my
girl wanna give a little smile with a
bang come
the pain the only thing to make it
they close
[Music]
with a crown
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know what to say that is
fantastic
look at you guys oh man that is exciting